j'ai envie de faire venir fabien olicard
maintenant pour qu'ils puissent analyser
son langage non verbal et savoir si ce
qu'il dit c'est de la merde ou non
[Musique]
et
mesdames et messieurs bonjour
aujourd'hui nous avons parlé de la zone
51 autrement appelée la zone loïc la
zone pastis parce que un volume d'eau
pour sept volumes de pastis je crois
c'est un truc comme ça bref zone 51 elle
fascine
ah [ __ ] j'ai mal là dedans quand je
prends le trop fort ça résonne dedans
j'ai mal à ma dans mamma dedans voulait
voir le pansement
on a vu parce que ça vous a intéressé
sur une odeur à 10 dans les commentaires
s'il vous plaît si vous savez que
j'avais un air qui était nécrosés est ce
que ça ne serait pas un coup des
extraterrestres la zone 51
et quel prix qu'est ce qu'on fait en
retour le belge ce qu'ils sont c'est
bien m
mais là c'est la question que je me pose
bref ça fait un bout de temps que vous
me demandez souvent d'analyser les
discours des politiques qui parlent de
la zone 51 mg as tu as lancé un appel on
est d'accord que lui déjà de base à une
voix d'extraterrestres le manger un
extincteur ou alors tu sais comme dans
men in black
ça s'ouvre il ya un petit extra
terrestre à l'intérieur c'est possible
j'ai envie de survenir fabien olicard
maintenant pour qu'ils puissent analyser
son langage non verbal et savoir si ce
qu'il dit c'est de la merde où nous je
suis dame à merde tu m'as parlé petite
vidéo manifeste toutefois dans l'espace
commentaires est claire nous bref je me
manifeste je suis la masse tu es je vais
essayer de trouver des informations à
donner parce que ça n'a pas l'air simple
quand même petit bis les moeurs
évidemment je vais utiliser des
techniques de verbal de non verbale
voire même de synergologie qu'à la base
une pseudo science dans laquelle des
fois je pioche des trucs parce que tout
n'est pas à jeter
bref ne prenez pas ce que je dis au
premier degré c'est mon analyse ça
n'engage que moi ne fait pas des vidéos
où vous reprenez ce que je vais dire là
en enlevant ce disque les moeurs merci
beaucoup de voix des sports le la
[Musique]
on fait une traduction tard elle s'il te
plaît le générique on m'a bien que vient
faire le trap temps réel des génériques
par des génériques
tu vois j'ai enlevé le loïc j'ai enlevé
de nohic sinon on ne peut pas le faire
je reprend directement sous titrage on
attend ce que tu fasses maintenant j'ai
rêvé j'ai fait un rêve seul ou samedi
c'est un serveur quand il te sais que le
jeu ait apporté le vert et il ne portait
comme ça du coup après disais ça ils
appuient dans mon dos et avec sa jambe
et je lui ai dit mais vous vous étiez à
la base militaire nous vous manipuliez
en ostéo en kiné et où il fait la wii
comment vous savez je dis hé mec tu
viens de me remettre le dos en place en
servant le coca c'est bizarre ou pas
alors que je bois puisque aucun des noms
tels que tout traduire c'est super long
au une minute trente deux c'est pas très
long abc mais bien sûr que non et on
fera des couples
si j'étais le président veut être
président loïc génériques
si il était le président quelque chose
qu'il était président non mais lui ouais
d'accord si jamais ouais il devenait
président quelque chose qui déjà fait la
question des langues qui trouve en
partie parce que c'est les grands
électeurs là bas donc ce cas le même
système qu'en france il en parle de ça
donc s'il était président
même si c'est très probable qu'ils ne
deviennent très peu probable très peu
probable
il a l'accent du sud non lui lui juste
après avoir touché les leviers pour
prêter serment et la dialectique tracé à
paul scholes est traduit rebelles mais
c'est non non non non non non et fabien
olicard la disent ah oui il dit bon non
basset trouve c'est une frame mais comme
bastian fait on m'appelle dans les
vidéos je vais mettre un numéro vert
appelez moi pelé lui pour les vendredis
que des kiss si jamais il était
président une fois qu'il aurait prêté
serment qu'ils iraient directement là où
il ya les files sur la zone 51 des
dossiers pour regarder directement de
ces compressions réponse d'obama à les
études
est ce que vous avez fait vous ne serez
pas président est un peu plus longtemps
chanté
non mais ce qu'il faut être fidèle après
dans la vie tu es final nous plaît des
fidèles dans la ville
il est dit que les extraterrestres ne
vous laisserai pas faire parce que ça
révélerait tous leurs secrets
mais ils disent en rigolant mais
regardez comme ils rigolent si on
regarde cela les stresse et oui oui fait
l'analyse
j'ai bien choisi a les oreilles plutôt à
taper la moitié tu fais à non je fais la
grève de la vidéo je fais la grève
toujours fut la cas où il faut que
j'analyse le non verbal on s'en fout que
pour l'instant il n'y a rien
d'intéressant
ils font des blagues comme notre vidéo
en fait y'a pas très intéressante et
blagues à huy des glaces à venir
peut-être intéressant parce qu'en plus
cela c'est exactement ce conseil demande
à ses 5 îles
ah oui il lui dit vous savez que là
comme je vous pose cette question il ya
plein de gens qui vont analyser de vos
mimiques vous regarde ce que vous allez
dire exactement comme hexagone mini qui
l'a dit mimiques comment tu dis mimiques
en mai mais je n'avais entendu fâchent à
l'expréssion j'avais pas tant des
mimiques oui mais c'est parce que c'est
une traduction pour que les gens et non
un [ __ ] loïc aller mais non c'est bon
t'as vu lé sur quoi ça angle là c'est
pas possible
alors comme la respiration qui
s'accélérait on le voit un sur son corps
de toutes tes débuts de stress regarde
pas si mal base il traduit traduit
moi-je analystes obama dit que lui peut
rien dire
et le présentateur dit pourtant un
président le président clinton lui est
allé regarder directement les dossiers
et après il a dit non il n'y a rien et
lui fait comme petite blague oui c'est
ce qu'on nous dit de dire bien effet
trop de blagues et en plus c'est des
ailes le fait vraiment rire en tout cas
la situation la muse alors est ce que
c'est parce que celle la muse de dire
moi je sais pas vous ou pas ce que juste
ça le fait rire les blagues mais quand
on regarde les yeux on a ce qu'on
appelle un sourire de duchenne on voit
avec les pattes d'oie avec les pommettes
etc
mais le meilleur moyen de voir sur air
de duchenne c'est une cache le bas du
visage et tu vois si ça a souri vraiment
enfin en fait ouais pas grand chose pour
commencer mais ne quittez pas la suite
va être in the l'air phénoménalement la
suite va être one for it
legendary telegent wake forest et alors
je sais ce que je vaux meet your face au
jeu vous regardez un peu les extraits
qui l'a diffusée masse tue parce que son
appel aussi concerne sa via que le vieux
monsieur
on est en fait une petite pause forcée
parce que il ya un livreur de colis
fanny à quesques mais j'avais déjà lu
loïc mais si c'est moi c'est mon nouveau
livre qui est sorti votre temps est
infinie c'est bien c'est incroyable
parce qu'il est il est premier des
ventes en ce moment grâce à vous merci
beaucoup
si vous l'avez pas lu je vous mets le
lien dans la description je vous ai fait
une vidéo détaillé à les sorties ya
quinze jours je crois sur le contenu du
livre c'est un essai sur le temps sur
votre temps bon bref famille arrive tu
vas pas trouvé bâtiment à
tiens je te le pass je disais c'est un
essai sur le temps sur votre temps
surmontant sa part de mon expérience
il ya toute ma philosophie du temps à
l'intérieur mais il ya aussi comment
s'organiser comment vraiment faire tout
ce qu'on veut et sait pas forcément
qu'ils travaillent faire ce qu'on veut
tu comprends loïc car ce qu'on veut
c'est aussi le temps pour soi le temps
personnel d'être avec les autres
y a pas que du temps de production quoi
bon bref je suis ravi de l'accueil que
vous avez fait et j'en profite à la
caméra pour dire merci beaucoup a big
flo et oli selon lui confier une stories
et sur le sujet est aussi à juliette des
leads et benjamin rabier aussi qui m'en
a parlé
bon bref donc merci à tous ceux qui
l'ont merci beaucoup en fait quoi t'as
pas couper les caméras ces bons chiffres
ont mis hockey si vous me s'il faut me
sipho me chifoumi chifoumi si toumi
chifoumi là à mon contrat pour ses
avantages mais c'est la technique d
autres qui font des vidéos sur internet
que je fais ils vivent leur vie
il y aura la vidéo et ça ça fait des
vues alors que moi j'ai vécu un petit
tunnel là ces quinze derniers jours de
bonnes vidéos qu'on me demande mais qui
font pas de lui du coup je fais je suis
du mainstream maintenant période tu vois
l'ancien fabien il aurait juste cliquer
là quoi garder secret une base mais de
nouveaux fabien il fait ça allez on y va
allez on va chercher nos vieux qui pue
il est là allez on rigole plus
[Musique]
tu dois regarder dans le vide comme si
fouiller dans sa mémoire pour les
chercher des souvenirs c'est incroyable
bref je vous laisse et extrait c'est
parti non juste le regard haut à droite
comme ça en pnl donc ça c'est la zone de
mémoire la zone de créativité c'est la
mémoire visuelle c'est quand tu cherches
un souvenir visuel dans ta tête
alors attention c'est fiable dans 30%
des cas on avait parlé sur la chaîne
mais ça donne toujours des indices tant
que tu es ex trop côté trouve ça si
incroyable que le gardien trop que tu
ais je vais aller voir diallo
mastur garde la vidéo est ce que tu
trouves que ça ça te met en valeur parce
que ça sera ma vigne est il ya trop de
kate évidemment hâte auscitains twitch
moi aussi j'ai un switch vous allez bien
de la discussion on va regarder
directement la ville la vidéo d'origine
en train d'analyser ces mouvements de
tête parce que il ay là je cherche la
baseline là une récurrence souvent il
baisse la tête comme ça et baissé la
tête
ça veut dire plein de choses ça peut
être de là on s'appelait plein de choses
mais si c'est très fréquent comme ça
pour un oui ou pour un non alors il faut
pas en tenir compte
là c'est ça que j'essaie de capter pour
l'instant là c'est très intéressant pour
nous parce que on sait qu'on va avoir la
vérité peu importe l'histoire est fausse
ou pas après on est quasiment certain
que le début de l'histoire est vraie
donc là on va avoir toute sa base sa
base militaire on voit toutes ses fins
de phrases à chaque fois il parle comme
ça et après il a la tête qui s'en va un
petit peu sur la droite un peu plus on
repère un espèce de rythmiques qui l'ont
verbal sur sur ces mouvements de
balancement qui là et on verra si on les
retrouve tout à l'heure enfin michelin
cus
signe de vérité également qui tend à
dire que là pour l'instant il dit la
vérité c'est les détails inutiles
le nombre de petits détails inutiles en
général quand on dit la vérité on
rajoute plein de détails parce qu'il
nous remonte au fur et à mesure on les
dit quand on est dans le mensonge on est
plus factuel on va plus à l'essentiel en
fait sans éprouver
il aurait pu dire dès le départ j'avais
un humain instructeur là bas qui m'a
pris sous son aile pas comme ça aurait
pu être aussi rapide que sa garde et du
chêne on voit vraiment dans les yeux tu
sais qui rit et serrières est tellement
sincère que c'est pas une blague qu'il
invente pour moi de tout ce que je vois
là on a les mêmes rites les mêmes
balancier les mêmes mouvements les mêmes
rythmes d'intonation pour moi il dit la
vérité jusque là en tout cas donc je
vais considérer que tout ce qu'il a dit
avancer ma zone de vérité et je pouvoir
la comparer avec ce qui va dire plus
tard déjà vu des pays inutile encore le
nombre de fois où le regarde pas dans
les yeux
c'est plutôt un symbole de vérité ça
aussi est ce que tu peux aller chercher
mon premier livre le bleu s'il te plaît
loïc lagarde
merci beaucoup de hits la garde donc mon
premier livre je cherche à ce que c'est
parce que c'est la version japonaise
ou chinoise plutôt que je galère c'est
possible merci beaucoup
chaque thème faire avec toutes les
versions de chaque pays alors attention
que dit mon premier livre que je prends
de référence signe de mensonges regard
fixe et là il fait que de décrocher de
regard en permanence quand on ment en
général on n'a pas besoin d'aller dans
ses souvenirs et c'est donc on peut
regarder l'autre dans les yeux et en
plus de ça on a besoin de vérifier
inconsciemment si lui même est en train
d'accepter le mensonge est donc là on a
regardé mon fixe mise à distance
pour l'instant on n'en a pas eu la mise
à distance pour reprendre l'exemple que
j'avais pris avec clinton c'est qu'on me
disait je n'ai pas eu de relation avec
monica lewinsky en fait il avait dit je
n'ai pas eu de relation avec cette femme
il dit ce temps ci alors que comme l'a
trahie camion dans lequel la pâle
l'appeler cette femme pourquoi ils
éloignent encore en sas à 6 mais mon
sens ok à voir merci beaucoup loïc
lagarde
c'est ce que ça fait là ma g ii au lit
car ça fait cordiale sherbrooke la
pareille en à dix on a un pléonasme
assez positif du oui corporelle et le
franchement c'est juste il est concerné
par ce qu'il dit on a encore tu vois les
yeux qui décroche à chaque fois qu'ils
cherchent un nom ça décroche dans la
mémoire et ça revient et je vous le dis
encore une fois en pnl même si ces
capitaux qu'à 30%
safe c'est la zone de creux de
créativité si on regarde sur sa droite
et la zone mémorielle s'ils regardent
sur sa gauche
et à chaque fois qu'il cherche un nom on
doit décrocher cherchèrent obtenir une
question qu'on peut se poser que
légitime c'est pourquoi on prendrait ce
mec un fermier et c est con qu'on
mettrait là dedans comment comment ça se
fait qu'on est aussi sûr de lui et qu'on
se pose pas les questions de
dire des choses pas dire des choses faut
se remettre dans le contexte à l'époque
y a pas internet il ya passé zorgane la
l'information elle se diffuse pas comme
aujourd'hui donc on craint pas trop à
engager quelqu'un qui n'est pas du tout
au fait de tout ça et elle le met dans
une base secrète parce que parce qu'il
n'ya pas grand risque quoi par un
journaliste deux camps parler encore
qu'il serait pas crédible parce qu'à
l'époque l'état contrôlé quand même pas
mal la presse
c'est important de le préciser parce que
aujourd'hui c'est très facile de
capturer quelque chose avec un téléphone
est tous là à l'époque nos alors là on a
plutôt des symboles de mensonges
à ce moment là mais peut-être aussi que
cette question parfois lâche qu'il a et
à la dette que cela peut-être que cette
question n'est pas pertinente en fait la
question c'est qu'est ce que vous avez
senti qu'on vous a dévoilé tout ça on
l'a vu il s'est redressé
il avait inspiré ses rangs français dans
le siège il a dit j'ai dit que il a il a
dit une phrase complète
c'est sûr qu'ils se souvient pas
exactement de la phrase qui lui a
traversé l'esprit à cette époque coup et
il était en regard fixe en plus sa mort
après cette attitude là mais ça remet
pas en cause tout ce qu'il va dire par
la suite en parle j'ai de ce moment là
et en même temps c'est assez normal si
je les ai aidés et loïc tanfin c'est
quoi exactement il ya vingt ans quand
tu es rentrée au collège donc tu as
pensé quoi quand tu es rentrée au
collège
bah oui tu sais pas tu sais pas
exactement tu peux penser et repenser un
peu l'état d'esprit global de ces
années-là et de dire je me suis dit que
mais ce serait un peu un mensonge tu
vois là c'est pour ça je pense qu'on a
des signes du mensonge [ __ ] là dedans
me fait mal sa mère je patine de
mensonge mais j'ai pas de signes de
vérité sur cette partie là donc je ne
sais pas si l'histoire du serment des
dattes etc
son vrai ou pas vrai c'est complètement
de cette rentrée c'est un vieux monsieur
qui bouge pas trop d'à pas trop
d'expression aux photos et aux
attaquants même un nom sur ce texte nova
tv jo est solide comme louis du québec
roger toute attente on a des mélanges de
signaux vous avez vu je peux vous leur
détailler de mensonges et de vérité mais
au global sur l'histoire sur la
structure de l'histoire on est plutôt
sur des signaux de vérité et après c'est
parfois dans les tout petits moments de
contenu des signaux de mensonge mais
encore une fois qu'on rapporte une
conversation
qui a eu lieu il ya plus de 50 ans c'est
très compliqué en fait de redire le mot
près donc ça ça m'étonne pas trop
par contre quand il parle de la
structure on a les mêmes signaux de
vérité qu'on avait en fait au tout début
donc moi je colle à sa chaumont
comparatif donc pour moi et que dit la
vérité dans tout ça ce cas c'est fou
quand même
en fait c'est intéressant de détailler
ce point là pour la crédibilité de la
suite aussi je trouve intéressant c'est
que il utilise des uns des mots faible
c'est à dire que apparemment tu vois il
semblerait que donc il dit ce qu'il a vu
et dans les hypothèses il est il et
soigne en bas alors que caen moment on a
tendance à utiliser plutôt des
superlatifs et je vous jure que j'ai vu
et c'était vraiment incroyablement et tu
vois hélas il n'y a pas de superlatifs
au contraire le mec a rien à prouver en
fait dans cette démarche c'est
intéressant
très loin oui vu au des fonds alors à
toute la partie là où il a commencé à se
remettre et c'est on a beaucoup de
signes parasie flics étaient si stoïque
et si calme on a les lèvres un peu
légèrement passé là ils regardent
vraiment l'autre comme quand on essaie
de savoir si l'autre et est content de
ce qu'on est en train de dire c'est
parti là là est moins crédible partir du
moment où il parle de s fort et de du
film pour le top 6 et ouais je citerai
que tous les signes de la main on a
beaucoup plus de stress que tout à
l'heure ça concerne tout le sait où vous
passez dans le regard j'ai un début de
conclusion vous inscrire au moscone west
europe at il rien non saturés
alors voici mes conclusions par rapport
à ce que j'ai vu je joue pas trop arrêté
pour pouvoir bien prendre le temps
d'analyser ces mêmes conclusions
en fait c'est mais concluant c'est comme
si on me disait et fabien tu en penses
quoi ce cap le masturber je te dit ce
que j'en pense
et encore une fois ça s'appuie sur ce
que je pense moi point je pense qu'il a
dit la vérité tout le long jusqu'au
hangar et le fait de voir les vaisseaux
je pense que tout ça est vrai je pense
pas qu'il ait vu d'alien directement
peut-être les films effectivement mais
je ne crois pas qu'il en ait rencontré
ça c'était pas assez crédible pour moi
je vais passer de symboles de vérité et
je ne pense pas qu'il ait revu les
présidents comme il dit après parce que
je récupère elles mêmes signes de stress
beaucoup de la main beaucoup de
remplacements
même quand il dit il avait l'air inquiet
et ses g si voilà si je mettais des gros
doutes ce serait sur la partie il a vu
des extraterrestres et il a fait ce
rapport là au président par contre tout
le reste qui était avant y compris le
fait d'avoir vu les vaisseaux et d'avoir
fait des films sur les aliens me paraît
extrêmement crédible en tout cas dans
son langage non verbal
moi j'ai pas énormément de chose en plus
a ajouté par contre si ça vous plaît je
vous propose un épisode 2 et vous me
mettez des billes en vidéo à gogo à gogo
les iaa j'ai dit à gogo et les mimiques
des mimiques à beauvau où il ya des
mimiques à gogo que nous pourrions de
analysés dans les commentaires vous
mettez ces liens c'est bien dans dans
les com et puis on sera un épisode de là
dessus mais là c'était un bon épisode
pour commencer pour répondre à la
question de notre ami ben astugue
j'espère que ça vous a plu
n'oubliez pas que la tournée de mon
spectacle continue avant que les
extraterrestres m'enlève pas ce que j'en
dis beaucoup trop venez me voir sur
scène dans sa bulle à cette ville à
cette ville si cette bulle là et vous
avez toutes les villes souvent sûrement
d'instagram c'est très joli joli
allez je vous embrasse embrasse banon
c'est compliqué vous êtes de l'autre
embrassez vous vous même quelque part de
ma part la cassette vidéo abonnez-vous à
très bientôt chao endroit c'est vous
quelque part de ma part
ah ouais non ah non pas là non toi tu me
diras